[Applaus]
[Musik]
mirja steht vor einer
lebertransplantation
[Musik]
ein eingriff der ihr leben retten soll
ich glaube die ist schon weg
[Musik]
macht's gut
werden
[Musik]
sie sind krank und wollen nichts als
leben
sie warten auf ein organ dass ein
verstorbener spendet ein leben geht zu
ende
eines wird verlängert die
organtransplantation ist ein eingriff
der bewegt es geht um ethik glaube
gesetz und moral um großes glück ich
freue mich darauf wie verrückt jetzt auf
diesen nächsten abschnitt immer im leben
und bin sehr dankbar dass ich das alles
erleben darf und um ängste was heißt die
transplantation für die empfängerinnen
und empfänger wie genau läuft sie am 20
die liebe ist sehr schön
wahnsinnig geduld
wie es die lebensqualität nach dem
großen eingriff es geht um warten
[Musik]
hoffnung und vielleicht erlösung
zur ist ein buch das ist armer junge
[Musik]
alaba wurde das leben der familie rast
dreht sich um die krankheit der tochter
doch sofort die gans in genf befindet
sich das lieber zentrum für kinder das
einzige in der schweiz leidet unter
einer extrem seltenen krankheit weltweit
sind nur ein paar wenige fälle bekannt
zurzeit geht es ihr gut sie besucht die
schule ein für andere kinder harmloser
infekt aber husten oder schnupfen kann
für sie lebensgefährlich werden
die eltern sind in ständiger sorge stehe
ich weiß aber auch geschafft vor gott
das beschäftige teil und das mir sehr
gewiss dass das blieb drin ereignisse
oder dann kann man nicht abschalten sich
also arbeiten sie transportation schon
zweimal erkrankte mirja schwer
sie hatte hohes fieber die leber
versagte seither hat ihre mutter keine
ruhe mehr
[Musik]
bald wird maria auf die sogenannte
dringlichkeitsliste für die
lebertransplantation gesetzt die zeit
drängt zu groß ist die gefahr dass sie
jetzt im winter wieder erkrankt
die koffer sind gepackt
[Musik]
wir müssen parat haben wenn alle telefon
und den müssen wir schnell schnell geben
als seite muss ich sie und
im bett liegt
[Musik]
anita lorang hat am universitätsspital
zürich schon zwei transplantationen
erlebt anita lorang litt unter
leberkrebs der man entschied sich vor
zwei jahren ihr einen teil seiner leber
zu spenden
die leber ist neben der niere das
einzige organ dass wir eine lebensspende
in betracht kommt
ja jetzt kämpfen zwei jahre
das ist eine option für diese gesprochen
schon jetzt aber ein paar tage nach der
transplantation ist klar
anita laurent muss in kürze nochmal
operiert werden
in ihrer leber ist ein gefäß verstopft
thrombose eine gefürchtete komplikation
ehemann alfred verabschiedet sich die
gestanks vorhang ist sie vor druck setzt
und das nicht ganz spende und nach der
operation dass es an beiträgen traurig
gestorben
und jetzt kriegt
ja
aber das sagen haben
heute fährt die 40-jährige noch alle
drei monate vom unterengadin zur
kontrolle nach zürich die werte sind gut
in jüngster zeit anita lorang erholt
sich
zum ersten mal seit dem stationären
aufenthalt gehen sie zurück auf die
intensivstation wo anita um ihr leben
kämpfte und ja das ist schon möglich ist
raus
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das kann jetzt also ich bin immer
optimist kämpfte und die weißheimer
monitor von kopien nach der operation
etwas nicht mit schwiegervater mit dem
rollstuhl oder so und dann ist
und obwohl die gefäß verstopfen rasch
behoben wird erholt sich an italo rohr
nicht zwei monate nach der
transplantation wird klar die thrombose
hat nachhaltigen schaden angerichtet
[Musik]
in der schweiz warten rund 200 menschen
auf eine leber insgesamt fehlen mehr als
1400 organe
jedes jahr sterben dutzende von menschen
die auf der warteliste sind nur wenige
schweizerinnen und schweizer halten fest
ob sie ihre organe spenden wollen oder
nicht
kein mensch befasst sich gerne mit der
eigenen endlichkeit
vier monate nach der transplantation ist
anita lorang immer noch im spital
mittlerweile ist klar die spenderleber
ihres mannes ist nichts zu retten
für die transplantation nicht
funktioniert
hani nid lepper sie schafft das ist die
komplikationen gehört aber das sei
möglich das ist deutlich zu unterbieten
andrea jetzt sie möglichkeit neuer krieg
[Musik]
das sind die chance kriegt weitere drei
monate muss ein italo noch durchhalten
dann wird er zum zweiten mal eine leber
transplantiert ohne komplikationen
das war vor eineinhalb jahren
sollte
[Musik]
ein quartier am rande von emmenbrücke
katja rast ist nur noch für ihre tochter
da ihre arbeit im restaurant einer
autobahnraststätte musste sie aufgeben
der erste zusammenbruch der tochter
ereignete sich vor sechs jahren in
katjas heimat in bulgarien
der zweite in der schweiz
der sarg von medikamenten
[Musik]
ende 2016 wiederholte sich der alptraum
am universitätsspital in genf erklärten
die ärzte dass mir ja wohl nicht
überleben werde
[Musik]
ja ich habe einfach nicht geglaubt dass
sie stirbt und ja bist du in ein loch
und sowie wie dein leben fertig ist weil
wirklich wann chips so passiert ich habe
studiert also mein leben ist auch
fertigen
ich wäre auch nicht gut mit der liebe
herr weil er für mich dass ich alles
[Musik]
marias freundinnen kennen die
krankheitsgeschichte und waren im spital
zu besuch
[Musik]
die erinnerungen an die schwierige zeit
sind immer da martin rast ist
selbstständiger landschaftsgärtner so
ist er jederzeit abkömmlich wenn mir er
ihn braucht
für ihn ist klar dass er nach einer
transplantation bei seiner tochter im
spital bleiben wird obwohl er gerne
arbeitet
ich studiere ich es auch machen und das
kommt nicht so gut
jeder beteiligte der vertrag muss immer
ein bisserl auf
somit eine ölschicht ja ich nicht gut
vertragen und blöd aber gut wenn z
er weiß dass seine frau wegen mir
schlaflose nächte hat sie locker
sie können aber nicht in ihrem auto
gerade dass man das was das nächste tor
auf und da sagen wir so der xxi
[Gelächter]
denkt immer dass mag sowie richtige
macho muss man würde sagen das sehe ich
da aber schon das sehr rasant
[Musik]
für einmal bleibt und rock aus bald wird
mirja auf die dringliche warteliste
gesetzt
dann kann alles schnell gehen
[Musik]
inselspital bern eines von sechs
transplantationszentren in der schweiz
hier werden herzen und lebern
transplantiert
vanessa bands ist leitende ärztin
das spezialgebiet der chirurgin ist
salopp gesagt der bauchraum sie ist
fiskal und transplantationsmedizin und
hätte sehr rasch verschlechtert
eine kühlbox im buch als anstatt die
mode als zeichen für eine anstalt und
andere krankheit und jetzt haben gestern
nacht das angebote berufen und im
idealfall wird der hütte transportiert
was ist natürlich wahnsinnig
morgen morgen logisch ist ja nicht so
richtig wissen ist noch nicht richtig
zwei ponys kattaka glücklicher bin ich
dass es großes also man hätte eigentlich
braun kommt dass man heute ablehnt aber
das werden wir es nicht zu sagen also
der effekt ist kaum kontrolliert jetzt
muss sich david der verfassung ist
zusätzlich der unterzuckerung zu
bestrafen wenn die kann man gar keine
top stoss ich oder nicht ausserdem fag
schlimmer wird jetzt vom ablauf hsv mit
gütern dass das okay ich bin froh dass
ganz wichtig wenn man die nach der
operation hatte
der horror-unfall und dann wartet der
initialen auf der intensivstation
besprochen und werde
rekord ist 63 in zwölf monaten hat der
50 kilo verloren
sein zustand hat sich rapide
verschlechtert jetzt sieht er licht am
ende des tunnels
[Musik]
das nimmt einem show match das sehen wir
nicht nur thema zwar operiere also ich
sehe technisch manuel der besuchstour
zersetze mit ein bisschen aber aufgrund
dessen dass es ein patient da sind wo
lagen auf der warteliste sind wichtig
sie zum teil wieder auch ob ich sie
wieder krank sie sind thomas wäre eine
beziehung mit ihnen und damit der
familien
[Musik]
rené eckardt hat einen holprigen weg vor
sich
bei seiner krankheit spielte früher auch
alkohol eine rolle
haben suchtkranke ein anrecht auf ein
organ
diese frage ist heftig umstritten das
gesetz sagt ja unter gewissen
voraussetzungen
[Musik]
verantwortlich für die organ zuteilung
ist die stiftung swisstransplant im
auftrag des bundes das computersystem
errechnet wer ein organ am dringlichsten
braucht ohne wertung hat sie dass der
einzelne patienten natürlich nicht
sofort der richter sieht es dafür große
suchtkrankheiten vorträge hat das
gericht das ist gelungen also mit der
lateinischen schweiz gleich eine
grundsätzliche mortem einig dass
erwarten ist doch und zu vernünftigen
kann jede frau ostermann fehler gemacht
wenn man die fahrer erkennt dazu steuert
und versagen so fertig jetzt ist anders
aber um punkt ihrer droge macht ihm auch
dass nico michaty dies trifft aber jetzt
ist fertig denn ich sehe mühe mit der
stellung der von vito sagte flügen auch
das gemacht
ramos im unterengadin anita laurent ist
endlich zurück bei ihrer familie nach
der operation ist so streng
die kinder mussten verantwortung
übernehmen aber die leute schoss es mir
gut geht dass sie nicht viel
als das ding nur langsam kam an italo
rang zu kräften
erst jetzt kann die familie das
geschehene aufarbeiten
die eltern mit sohn aurelio und den
13-jährigen zwillingsmädchen
ich habe schlechte prognose körper dem
sap-system liga noch weiter wachsen und
die einzige möglichkeit ist es sicher
cleverer verrückten überholen und mit
seinen täglich blockaden und ich mach
das
frank ist es wird mit einfachen ersten
tag sei das wird schwierig werden für
sie ab die nach ihm versprochen dass sie
alles probiert aber die animiert seit
ich gar nichts lieber gott
transplantieren der bin ich wieder
gesund
das heimrennen
die nachricht dass der vater einen teil
seiner leber spenden will hat die kinder
erschreckt ganz links den
lieblingsseiten das machen denn de
maizière
roswitha dass wir bei den sozial und den
sie mit den noch zu wenig bietet
bespreche ich sie und zu wenig professor
linek und in einer exakt muss meine
tochter und deshalb den euro von zenit
hinter dass die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
sie tun erfahren dass staat grössere ist
als dass sie nicht zur kooperation der
beruf und daniela das zeitung den fcd
sofa zeit wenn er sagt er hat dann in
diesem markt sehr suspekt ich einfach so
an schließt also wirklich so als im
inselspital ist vanessa bands unterwegs
zum nächsten patienten es geht um ein
erstes aufklärungsgespräch besser keine
läden
dass sie rasch wieder zähler was heißt
eigentlich thompson tattoo model ist 68
nach der pensionierung tauchte beim
früheren sbb arbeiter leberkrebs auf ein
tumor wurde kürzlich erfolgreich
entfernt
jetzt fühlt er sich gut ich sind wir
super sei geeignet
dazu uns kandidat will apple ja ich habe
mich einfach unsere monik schwarzrock
durchschnitt worte es wirklich nur ein
mathematisches unfall muss man
überbrücken und war okay ich sehe serie
für ein erstes aufklärungsgespräch nimmt
sich vanessa bands dreiviertel stunden
zeit jeder patient soll genau wissen was
auf ihn zukommt und die risiken kennen
nur wenige aber es kommt nicht gar nicht
ab und suchen so aber dass mit den jetzt
was haben die für frage ich habe merkte
jedoch sehe ich keine das war ein bis
fünf jahren
also lasst es ist wenn man sich
entscheide für transplantationen denkt
damit nicht warten bis es zu rücken
das ist wenig einschätze wenn's so grund
und wie es kommt zu gern hätte er
kurbelt die operation aufgeschoben
es geht ja aber ihr kordel sagt ja zur
transplantation bald werde aktiv auf die
warteliste kommen
[Musik]
universitätsspital genf es geht gegen
mitternacht
spät am abend wurde mirja aufgeboten zur
transplantation
ihr vater reist im auto an
ich weiß nicht mehr ob sie treffsicher
operationssaal in nicht und noch das
recht stellung bezieht
der vorstand wird
die voruntersuchungen werden stunden
dauern
[Musik]
eine transplantation hat mir ja noch nie
erlebt aber die erinnerung an frühere
spitalaufenthalte sind ein alptraum für
sie inzwischen ist auch martin rast
eingetroffen
im gepäck ein plüschtier
noch gut ja martin rast ist froh bei den
vorbereitungen dabei sein zu können
untersuchungen blutentnahme röntgen
marias gesundheitszustand mit minutiös
überprüft
noch ist an schlaf nicht zu denken
obwohl sie die transplantation
herbeisehnten steigt bei den eltern die
angst
miriam ist verschiedene medikamente zu
sich nehmen
das ist genau wie medikamente ich weiß
nicht genau wie der kleinen patientin
wird alles zu viel
medikamente sind schrecklich für sie
schon früher hatte sie mühe damit
die minuten wir hätten zu stunden
da ist wie eine lawine schädel wo die
nicht ich wollte ihnen jede
unterstützung die ein buch wie eine ganz
kleine filme
[Musik]
rocco
wie stark ich glaube
[Musik]
er fragt sich ob nicht ihre mit ihrem
medikament könnte sich die letzte chance
[Musik]
der stress genommen
es wird eine turbulente und kurzer nacht
vor dem großen eingriff
[Musik]
familie laurent bricht auf in ehemals es
das thema organspende beschäftigte an
italo rang schon in jungen jahren mit 14
besorgte sie sich einen
organspendeausweis hat als ich das will
und das ist schon mal nicht so einfach
sieht einfach können also einen ehe
gehört die verteilung der organe ist im
transplantationsgesetz geregelt die
medizinische dringlichkeit hat erste
priorität
das heißt ein älterer mann hat die
gleichen chancen wie eine jüngere frau
mit drei kindern
für mich auch schwierig sie zum teil
wenn ich denken kann ja meine frau ist
gesundheit gesund gelebt
mir graut rundheit gesund käßmann von
drei kinder und kriegt kaliber und einer
wegen alkohol- drogen- alkohol- oder
schlicht der hätte lieber vor ihrer
clique und das ist dass ich in
öffentlicher hand und nicht von
emotionen
das kann es nicht sein dass das kann die
funktionäre so schon tatsächlich
errechnet ein algorithmus wer als
empfänger an erster stelle kommt nach
der dringlichkeit geht es auch um den
medizinischen nutzen
zu wem passt ein organ am besten wer
profitiert am meisten
[Musik]
für anita laurent war die organspende
lebensrettend die erlebnisse rund um die
zweite transplantation sind noch präsent
[Musik]
ich bin jetzt fröhlich und freue mich so
viel glück und führt an dass im moment
liegt gerade im sterben und das ist
schwierig das ist sehr schwierig sie
ich habe gespürt dass die person mir das
game geht ja ich glaube darum gottes aus
vergütung passt das auch so gut wie gut
die energie neugierig sie vorerst jedoch
jeden tag jeden tag denke geschichte
person kennengelernt aber im richtigen
leben gott sitzt halt nicht aber ich
rede viel mit einer person ja jeden tag
forscht die empfänger dürfen die spender
familie nicht kennenlernen
es gilt das prinzip der anonymität der
new york muss sie angst dass er
abhängigkeiten stellt so gerade druck
oder vorträge konnten starterset mit
sich anrufer in die organspende schenkt
sich unentgeltlich und das unbedingt das
so bliebe es geht möglichkeit anonym
der verlust sei leider wird es ganz
wenig nutzt william turner jetzt für
mich eine brief gar nicht was das
bedeutet das dass krankheit und ist
letztendlich bedingt ist anita laurent
möchte irgendwann wieder in ihren beruf
als kindergärtnerin zurückkehren wo man
die zwei gewöhnen autos so laden die
grenze um angriffen seien entscheidungen
treffen operation ja oder nein aber wenn
man will aber der mensch muss der fülle
auch entscheiden will zuschießt sich
noch ist sport
[Musik]
am unispital genf rückt marias
operationstermin er die co-leiterin des
leber zentrums barbara wildhaber kommt
zur letzten visite von bis 20 bis 22
schön dass es jetzt richtig linux die
kurz bewusstlos
die noobs was heißt kann das ist nicht
groß
ja es genau so dass cancellara hat heute
mittag aber welche mehr schlaf sowieso
die ganze zeit völlig ist es nämlich
viel weniger schlimm als ihr euch das
vorstellen
frau musica vocalis mir ja also das
ganze jahresmitte und der könnt sie
ertrinken und böse verrat weiß ich nicht
aber den lauf
wir sind
[Musik]
ich habe ehrlich sein mitstreiter wie
die erste die sind es so klar dass ich
eine nacht an dem modell ab dann gern
schon zweimal die tochter wirklich
praktisch verloren jetzt ganze sie ab
und version etwas passiert ich weiß es
ich kontrolliert aber sie wisse der unit
und sie sind die den songs für die
tochter will sie natürlich weiß auch
gehört hat ist diese decken
[Musik]
ja
tschüss
machs gut
ich nehme teil
marx gut
[Musik]
hus
genf ist das einzige
transplantationszentrum in der schweiz
dass die leber bei kindern
transplantieren darf routine ist dieser
eingriff aber nie
noch ist die spenderleber für mir ja
nicht eingetroffen
der zeitplan ist genau kalkuliert allein
die entnahme der kranken leber wird
stunden in anspruch nehmen
barbara wildhaber ruft zum timeout bei
dem routinemäßig die identität des
patienten und die art des eingriffs
geprüft wird
name der us-operation stelle bauch art
des eingriffs wechsel der leber lady
wird die leber abholen frisch wir machen
nichts damit aber sie ist sehr wertvoll
die ganze welt interessiert sich dafür
marias leber soll genau untersucht
werden um ihrer noch wenig erforschten
gen krankheit auf die spur zu kommen
die transplantation kann beginnen
ich bin
b
in der nächsten sendung die lange
operation wird für katja und martin rast
zur zerreißprobe
bruno roman wartet auf ein spenderherz
wiedersehen mit dem patienten rené
eckardt er hat nach der transplantation
eine schwere zeit erlebt und wie sieht
eine transplantation auf seite des
organspenders aus in der nächsten folge
von ich will leben
[Musik]